do you see a time where a company could
deploy these and say hey listen you're
coming in as a doctor
you're coming in as a card dealer
blackjack dealer
we need you to have a score on your aura
ring
of readiness of 70 or better or 80 or
better or your average has to be 80 or
better now i know this seems orwellian
but for a bus driver or a pilot we
already
give them requirements of sleep
sometimes they do it sometimes they
don't we give them
requirements for how often they can fly
i would love
to know that my pilot on the plane i'm
putting my family on
is uh has an aurawellian approach to
this
if i may that they have to wear an or a
ring
and we need to know they're ready to fly
has that
this must have come up inside your
organization
what is the discussion like inside your
organization and with other
organizations about
the line between personal privacy
and you know being ready to do good work
like i i don't think office workers need
to
i mean obviously it would be great but
it would also feel orwellian
but for a pilot or a brain surgeon or
any kind of surgeon this does not feel
orwellian
yeah for them to be wearing one what are
the conversations been like for you guys
internally about
doing something like this because
obviously you've talked about it oh yeah
look we formed a whole
ethics committee a process a framework
um
frankly we even joined um the world
economic forum has
has a panel that they put together on
you know iot and creating
trustworthiness and iot devices because
how you shared this data
um so a couple things we did everything
has to be 100 opt-in
we never want to have anyone forced
frankly even in that that pilot
situation i just think we're not there
yet
to take a stance on that i think our big
view is education tell you the
passengers are
no i i know but i mean you know at the
same time
i think rather than force people i'd
rather
see them educate and understand if that
pilot understood or or frankly your uber
driver
hey you know six hours or four hours of
sleep right you're you're
yeah yeah it's dangerous right your
chance of getting an accident goes up
for 40 percent train truck driver right
truck driver oh my god no brainer
yeah and those are places where they're
under let's be honest they're under
pressure
to do more these from what i understand
the amazon drivers there was a lot of
controversy who knows how much of this
is true in the fake news but
you know there was some controversy that
maybe the freelancers were going a
little too hard trying to deliver
packages a little too aggressively to
hit windows
and cause accidents you know and i don't
know if it's true or not but
okay so opt-in is one opt-in and then
what are the others
so de-identified um you know figure out
frameworks to share this data on a
population level
and empower the end user so for example
our health risk management
um use the admin i can't see that
jason's getting sick today
what i can see is hey of my group of 10
that's coming in the office
someone looks like they're getting sick
today what do you see jason we want to
empower you you get a message in the app
hey got it go see nick before you come
in today give nick a call you can
actually customize that so it would be
the same thing with if i had an employee
who was suffering from mental illness
they go see the hr department i don't
know what mental illness they have i
don't know why they went to see the hr
department but i do know they're taking
a leave of absence for two weeks it
could be
their their mom died and they're
grieving it could be they're having
panic attacks
it's not my job as the manager to know
what the ailment is it's just to know
that they
they're getting help so they can get
back in the game
correct yeah so i think we were like
de-identified
create frameworks and ways to empower
the individual you know notify them
first
our team i honestly credit off to our
team through thinking all this stuff um
even putting an ethics framework
together
i think any time we looked at where you
can potentially
you know be if we we even have put in
our contracts where like if this data is
used and then someone is terminated
because the result of the data
right like you know we're going to we
have the right to cancel a contract
because you know we don't want people
but if you think about it that's a great
big brother now yes i'm not saying you
know
eventually we're figuring this out as a
company we don't have all the answers
but we've talked to lots and lots of
these different types of frameworks and
different types of companies
and you know how are those companies if
you de-anonymized a company
that was in you know the business of you
know one person's
responsible for a lot of people's safety
you know like
if so if the ring let you know the
person was on meth and on a bender every
night
or you know out drinking every night and
just disregarded sleep
you kind of actually would want to
reprimand or fire that person
so it's nice that you want to take this
stand but
i mean no we've we've found more buy-in
from companies because they don't want
to get in trouble looking at this data
either
right so there's a concern about that
exactly
so i think companies actually want
de-identified and cool tools and
frameworks like we've created
to still empower the individual right
they don't want to know
what's happening to that person nor
should they right what they do want to
know is
hey empower that person to get help and
get help faster right that's what they
want to be able to do
so you would be okay theoretically i
love that you're willing to talk about
this because it's just such a
i don't know if i said i'm willing you
just started asking me all right
well anyway we can make this
hypothetical right so
in in the hypothetical example just
thinking out the
morality question here if a person was
struggling
with alcoholism was not sleeping and
they were responsible for other people's
health
and their apple watch fitbit or other
device
let's just say a device not your device
would know that you wouldn't want
them to be fired you would want them to
get a notification i like this framework
they got a notification
hey you're not you're not you don't have
enough restfulness and sleep to do your
job properly
please report to the hr department
tomorrow
yeah and the hr department would tell
them we just need to check in on
somebody's suitability
for being on the job they're not going
to make their shift today or tomorrow
and then there's an intervention where
they just discuss it like hey listen is
the ring broken let's give you a new one
or is the watch broke and we can give
you a new one or
is there anything we should know do you
need a two-week leave of absence to kind
of tighten this up
there is a way to do it that's
compassionate that doesn't embarrass the
person that doesn't
make them lose their job but that does
let them know
your job is pretty serious if you want
to be at the yoke of that plane
or that controller of that train you
you cannot get this level of sleep we
need to get a sleep level that's
to measure it with the risk of you know
the
doing the job poorly i i think that's
exactly how we've
in our team has come up with ideas of
thinking about it and frameworks
you want to empower the individual what
you want to do is right teach that
person that like
hey get in four hours of sleep five
minutes in a row
means like you're at a really heightened
risk for an accident by the way that's
not just bad for the passengers it's
probably bad for you and your family
yeah because you're at the front of the
train
yeah so conductor and the pilot die
first
most of the time most of the time right
so generally go down with the ship
let me ask you another tough question
since we're at the end and i always ask
the hardest ones then when i got the
guests warmed up
and you're so good you're so honest
i got an honest guess here um